totally yeah yeah man I mean what music
do you listen to like who are your
favorite artists wow yeah that's a tough
question I like every type of music
all of it yeah rap country Bluegrass yup
yup so you enjoy music yeah I'm a big
music listener you're a terrible person
what why here we go you realize I'm just
asking that question because I want to
get to know you better you don't have to
rank every song you listen to just give
me an idea of who you are but I like
everything you like this
show me your Spotify rap I use apple
music of course you do what name one
artist you like Dolly Parton [__] you
why everyone loves Dolly Parton she's
great who are you whoever you want me to
be the second I met you I knew you judge
me for my taste in music so I won't tell
you I won't I'm sorry yeah I'll be less
judgmental and if you're so curious
lately I've been listening to the
Hamilton soundtrack Hamilton in 2023
what are you a 40 year old Drama teacher
who's also a virgin ah I'm sorry
[Music]